le secrétaire général de la cgt m vient
mettre au point son plan de bataille
gabriel jean marie veut s'attaquer à une
prix de fin de contrat à verser aux
gérants de stations service l'an dernier
certains auraient touché une somme
allant jusqu'à 230 mille euros à la fin
de leur contrat de trois ans ils ne
veulent absolument pas communiquer là
dessus parce qu'ils disent régulièrement
que c'est pour notre retraite non c'est
pas pour notre retraite
c'est une recette d'exploitation qui
doit être prise en compte dans le calcul
des recettes et qui doit être prise en
compte également lorsqu'on détermine la
rémunération aussi des employés de
stations service et les géants font le
blatter dessus et c'est pour cette
raison que nous avons dit que c'est un
racket chaque année c'est la sara qui
collectent et 7 frime l'an dernier plus
de 2 millions d'euros que les gérants en
fin de contrat avec les pétroliers se
sont partagé pour la raffinerie rien de
nouveau ni d'illégal
la prima ip est prévue par arrêté
préfectoral dans le prix réglementé par
l'état au même titre que les marges et
des grossistes des détaillants et des
taxes cette ligne est reversée par la
sara aux gérants de stations services à
des associations de gérants de stations
service et elle est destinée à
indemniser les gérants sur leur fin de
contrat puisque effectivement ce que
l'on sait peut-être pas c'est que les
gérants des contrats à durées courtes
alors les courtiers quelques années je
connais pas les choses en détail et que
si une sorte d' indemnité de précarité
comme on retrouve sur les cdd par
exemple pour gabriel jean marie ce n'est
pas aux consommateurs de supporter cette
prime mais aux grossistes à savoir les
pétroliers il promet des actions futures
de la cgt